>>Male Presenter: We're really glad that David
Malki ! could be here today. Many of us know
him as the creator of Wondermark, which he's
devoting his time from a career that involved
editing Hollywood movie trailers, which is
something I'm also a big fan of.
We are especially glad to have him here because
as many of you know we have a lot of people
working here on Google Books and we make all
books available in the hopes that awesome
things like Wondermark will happen for making
all these whole things possible. So, David,
thank you very much.
And he's here to talk about "True Stuff From
Old Books." Yes, right.
[applause]
>>David Malki: Thank you. Thank you very much.
Thanks for the invitation. Come on in. My
name is David Malki. I'm a comic strip author.
Mark told me you may be familiar with it.
If not, I'll give you a little bit of an overview
by virtue of showing you an episode. And I'll
read it to you.
You got a guy on a phone here. He's listening
to the phone and it says, "Your call is very
important to us. Please listen carefully as
our menu options have recently changed. For
billing, press one. For sales, press two.
For technical support, press pi. If you know
your party's extension, you may dial it in
reverse order using your touchtone phone.
To access the company directory, please hold
your phone receiver over a stove and watch
the patterns the steam makes when viewed against
a dark background. To report a lost or stolen
card, twist the receiver in opposite directions
with both hands. Have a resealable glass container
nearby to catch the liquid that emerges from
the earpiece.
In a dark, quiet room, press your face against
the mouth of the container and tell the liquid
exactly what happened to your card. The vivid
memories are best, the good times your card
enabled you to have. Tell it all this and
seal it. Let the liquid harden into a gel
in a cool cupboard.
In seven to ten business days, you will receive
a pack of seeds. Plant the seeds in the gel
in the shape of a regular hexagon." He's thinking,
"Man, these options have changed."
[laughter]
So, comics like this are--. They run on our
website twice a week and I make it an interesting
way. I make them out of the pieces of other
illustrations, which come from catalogs, magazines,
books, all sorts of things from the Victorian
era.
Typically, the 1860s through the 1890s, which
was the era when engraving reached a high
art and before photography put all those guys
out of jobs. So, they guy on the left here
is made of all these different pieces, different
shapes, different chunks, Frankenstein-style
from different images.
It's like playing with Legos. Legos are the
crafts of old dead people. Here's another
example. Here's a guy with a little motorized
bike. And maybe I want some kind of sailboat
with a propeller on it. Look by the windmill.
How about a Sears catalog full of gears and
gizmos and sprockets?
And you take them all apart and put some other
things together and now you got this guy.
[laughter]
He is, of course, on the cover of the books
you have there, "Dapper Caps and Pedal-Copters."
And making things like this out of other things,
I think, is a really constructive process.
And it's really fun. And it's a different
way to make comics than most other people's.
So, I'm really happy to accidently stumble
across this amazing technique. I'm not the
first to come up it. And I have not been the
last. But I'm clearly the best.
[laughter]
I get the images from old books. In this particular
case, this was a box that a lady in Nova Scotia
sent me from her library. They otherwise would
have been thrown away.
She emailed me and said, "Would you like these?"
And I said yes. So, I received the box in
the mail followed by two others in rapid succession.
And they're full of these cool old images
and I'll page through them. And I'll look
for very interesting things that I can use
to make comics.
But the cool thing is that when I look through
these books, I get captivated by the articles
and by the stories. And I end up reading things
I never would have encountered before. And
that's what all this stuff I'm gonna show
you today is about. It's the stuff that I
found that provides a little window into this
period of a hundred years ago.
For example, "The Albany Argus has espoused
the beard movement." This article is from
the 1870s. This is his argument. "We have
come to the conclusion that the practice of
shaving is alike ridiculous and absurd, and
that it violates one of the laws of nature.
Now, our beard was not given us for no purpose;
that is evident. It was created for some wise
purpose, and that was to keep the face and
throat warm, and thus be conducive to health.
Let us look at a few facts. It has been calculated
that if one shaves three times a week, it
grows twenty times as fast as if he did not
shave.
Allowing two inches as the annual growth of
the beard, it will be seen that a man cuts
off forty inches, or more than a yard of hair
a year, and the nutriment which supports this,
and is thus wasted, might have gone to nourish
other parts of his body, and render him a
healthy and handsome man."
[laughter]
"Again, allowing twenty minutes to each shaving
operation, three times a week, amounts to
one hour a week, 52 hours a year. Supposing
a man to shave forty years, we find he has
consumed about three months in the simple
act of shaving.
And calculating the expense of each operation
at the small sum of six cents, we find it
has cost him 360 dollars"
[laughter]
"In view of these facts, we cannot but regard
the practice of shaving as a decidedly barbarous
one, and which ought to be discountenced by
the progressive civilization of the age."
This is the sort of thing that shows up in
a newspaper back in the 1800s.
Two things I want to point out to you. Number
one is "barbarous."
[laughter]
Number two is "discountenance."
The Victorians loved puns. They loved puns.
It's ridiculous how much they loved puns.
You see a lot more of this. The pun is the
highest form of Victorian humor. The other
cool thing is finding not just strange windows
into things like the beard movement, which
was from 1840 to 1900, but inventions that
seemed like great ideas but for some reason
never quite caught on.
This is from an issue of Scientific American
magazine, Gentilli's glossograph. Any idea
what the glossograph might be for? Any ideas
at all?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #1: You put your head
on the little stirrups on the left right there?
>>David Malki: You put your head in the little
stirrups. The thing is about this big.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #1: OK.
>>David Malki: So, probably not. But it's
a very good guess. Someone said "the tongue."
It's also a very good guess. Let's read about
it.
[reads from article]
"An easily managed instrument, shown in Figure
One, is provided with delicate levers which
rest upon the different parts of the tongue
and lips, and slender wings swing before the
nostrils. The levers of this instrument may
be taken in the mouth without any inconvenience."
[laughter]
So, that top graph, you see those arcs? Those
are the things that sit in your mouth and
rest on your tongue and lips.
[continues reading]
"On speaking, these levers and the wings move,
and their motions are transferred partly in
a mechanical way and partly by electricity
to a writing pencil, which marks the single
sound with great precision upon six lines
parallel and near to each other on a strip
of paper, which is moved forward by hand or
clockwork."
"Upon the utterance of the vowels and consonants,
moving one or more parts of the organs of
speech more or less strongly, or upon the
air exhaled through the nose, the signs corresponding
to the sounds uttered are recorded and may
be read at once."
So, this bottom graph, this seismograph, is
the record of how you your lips have moved.
[continues reading]
"Stenography through the use of this apparatus,
which the inventor calls a glossograph, becomes,
in a certain measure, the public property
of everyone who will undertake the easy and
interesting labor of learning the key of this
'nature's self-writing.' This apparatus may
be used for the recording of public speeches,
not by the orator himself, but by one employed
for that purpose, who takes the instrument
in his mouth and repeats the speech softly,
for the voice plays no part in bringing out
the signs."
So, let me explain this. This device sits
in your mouth and someone is up here talking
like I am. And someone else, off to the side,
is mouthing the speech and the strip of paper
is--
[laughter]
coming out. And then later this is spooled
up and someone, I guess, can read it. It's
a really, though, a very efficient way to
record the information.
[continues reading]
"The glossograph has the advantage over stenography
as it is practiced now, as it requires no
previous study or practice. It demands no
straining of the attention, just say the words
and it does all the work."
Right? Labor-saving device. That's the promise
of technology.
[continues reading]
"And consequently causes no weariness. Only
the deciphering requires practice. The employment
of an apparatus which will enable us to write
four or five times as rapidly as formerly,
especially in an age when so much writing
is done as in ours, will not be confined to
the noting down of public speeches, and if
the compass of the practical value of this
invention has only been glanced at, it must
be perceived that there is a fruitful principle
in it which is capable of great development."
Never caught on. Don't really know why.
[laughter]
But here is another example of the sort of
thing that Scientific American will print.
And you'll go from the glossograph to this
[snaps finger] in just no time flat one after
the other, the Cornell Owl.
[reads article]
"During the past week, a bittern, a duck,
and four owls have been received at the laboratory.
One of the owls is kept alive."
So, something happened to everything else.
[laughter]
[continues reading]
"He has disposed of parts of several fish,
a chipmunk, and a live snake two feet long.
The encounter with the snake was quite amusing."
[laughter]
"The owl, on spying him in a glass case, evinced
a desire to form a closer acquaintance, and
so the snake was placed on the floor of the
laboratory."
This is what I like about these scientists.
[laughter]
He said the snake is in a case. The owl can't
get to him. But let's solve that one.
[laughter]
Put them together. Probably take very careful
notes.
[laughter]
"The owl with one fell swoop came down upon
his snakeship--"
[laughter]
"and in striking his claws into his back,
raised his head to his mouth and instantly
smashed it. Then commenced the process of
deglutition. The owl proceeded to swallow
the snake's head first, and proceeded badly
enough, until, after a minute's struggle,
all was swallowed but two inches of the tail."
“At this point, the owl stopped to take
breath, and stood with its eyes slowly blinking,
while the two inches of tail, while still
visible, was wiggling vigorously. At last,
summoning of courage, the owl gave a last
struggle and the end of the tail disappeared,
still wiggling down his throat."
Scientific American magazine.
[laughter]
There is a real, I think, interesting observation
here that we can make in retrospect. And that
is they're very interested in inventions and
they're very interested in things that go
in your mouth and record stenography.
[laughter]
But they're also very interested in things
that are just weird. And they're like, "We
gotta write this down. We can't let this just
vanish. This experience that we all had in
this laboratory, watching this owl eat this
snake, someone's writing this down, right?
Let's send it to Scientific American."
Scientific American, to their credit, said,
"Awesome."
[laughter]
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #2: This is YouTube.
>>David Malki: Yeah. This is YouTube of a
hundred years ago. Everyone's sitting around
saying, "Did the new issue come in yet?" And
then someone reads it like I just did. Here's
another example. This is just the tiniest
scrap in a giant newspaper full of all sorts
of other things.
[reads article]
"One of these papers which are very pleasant
light reading is--"
And this is actually a review paper of other
books and magazines. So, it's basically short,
synopsis, capsule summaries of other things
out in the public at that time.
"One of these papers which are very pleasant
light reading is General Middleton's paper
in the United Service Magazine, entitled,
'An Old Soldier's Pets.'"
"They were his fellows: a Capuchin monkey,
a young kangaroo, a magpie, which saved itself
on one occasion from being worried by a dog
by whistling the first three or four parts
of 'Nix my Dolly, pals;' a nilgai, which is
something of a horse creature, which he tried
to ride, and which nearly killed him; a couple
of mongooses, two young tigers, a couple of
monkeys, an otter, and a small black bear.
Most of these animals came to a violent end."
[laughter]
I tried to find the actual paper, "An Old
Soldier's Pets," and I could not find it on
Google books, so get on that. But I did find
several other newspapers citing how amazing
that thing was.
They're all basically like this. Guys, you
gotta read "An Old Soldier's Pets" because
this guy's menagerie is amazing. And here
is another example of the heady, adventure-seeking
spirit of the age. Have any of you ever heard
of Hiram S Maxim? He was a very famous gunsmith,
electrician, and inventor. He was from the
United States.
From Maine, he ended up moving to England
and became a British subject. And in the 1890s,
he invented a flying machine. He was one of
many people working on flying machines, prior
to the Wright Brothers. And this is a little
article from 1893 explaining all about his
flying machine. It was steam-powered. It had
a boiler on board.
[laughter]
So, this image is of the machine on the rails,
as it appeared in 1893. This is the machine
of 1893 as it would appear in the air. The
is the starboard side of the machine after
the accident.
[laughter]
It didn't work as well as he would've thought.
But for not the reason you might expect. This
is the really interesting thing. Here's Hiram
Maxim himself. And this guy was a curmudgeon.
I found his autobiography on Google Books
and it's a delightful read because everything
is "this great invention" and then "the people
who hated me for it."
And "this guy wanted to charge me 200 pounds
to chop down the trees on my own property.
Meanwhile, I'm inventing a flying machine."
And this goes back and forth, back and forth.
It's really fascinating. But here's what he
has to say. And this is a paper he wrote for
a research journal.
[reads article]
"At the time I commenced my experiments in
aeronautics, it was not generally believed
that it would ever be possible to make a large
machine, heavier than the air, that would
lift itself from the earth by dynamic energy
generated by the machine itself. It is true
that a great number of experiments had been
made with balloons, but these are in no sense
true flying machines."
"Everyone who attempted a solution to the
question by machines heavier than the air,
was looked upon in very much the same light
as a man who now attempts to construct a perpetual
motion machine."
"Up to within a few years, nearly all experiments
in aerial navigation by flying machines have
been made by men not versed in science, and
who, for the most part, have been ignorant
of the most rudimentary laws of dynamics.
It's only quite recently that scientific engineers
have taken up the question and removed it
from the hands of charlatans and mountebanks."
Mountebanks is a word I'd like to bring back.
"A few years ago, many engineers would not
have dared to face the ridicule, which they
would be liable to receive if they had asserted
that it be possible to make a machine that
would lift itself by mechanical means into
the air."
"However, thanks to the admirable work of
Professor Langley, Professor Thurston, Mister
Chanute and others, one may now express his
opinion freely on the subject and speculate
as to the possibilities of making flying machines,
without being relegated to the realm of cranks
and fanatics."
So, this decade of the 1890s was when the
science of powered flight was really starting
to come into real, under scientific scrutiny.
He, Hiram Maxim, was such an inventor and
so wealthy by this point, that he could build
giant machines.
And he had a hanger out there near London
where he was building his experiments and
he built multiple propellers to see which
would work the most efficiently in the air.
And he is really dedicated to solving this
problem. This is a latter-day artist's representation
of what happened on his most successful, and
last, flight.
The machine--. And the reason he used the
steam boiler was not because he was an idiot,
but because at the time it was the most efficient
per pound, horsepower per pound. And he had
a rail that he ran that ship on. And he had
another rail balanced above it because he
didn’t' want the thing to go too high and
to actually collapse.
He just wanted to learn if he could control
it for that six inches. So, the thing went
down the rail and it lifted off, and it hit
that top rail. And it broke the top rail because
it had this great up, burst of lift. And it
actually snapped the track and it fell over
and it was destroyed.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: So, he made it.
>>David Malki: So he made it. That's the thing.
He made it horribly uncontrollably, but he
made it. This is what he says about the accident.
[reads from article]
"I found myself floating in the air with the
feeling of being in a boat, but unfortunately,
a piece of the broken plank struck one of
the screws, the propellers, and smashed it.
I instantly shut off steam and the machine
came to a state of rest on the earth, the
wheels cutting deeply into the ground and
leaving no track, thus showing that they had
sunk down vertically and had not run along
the ground before settling.
“This was the first time in the history
of the world that a flying machine actually
lifted itself and a man into the air."
1893. Now, he goes on to talk about, "The
machine was practically the same as the Farman
machine" and so on. "If I had a larger field,"
the quantity of water was too much.
Here are all the things I can fix. "Shortly
after this accident, I received notice from
the landlord that the property had been sold
to the London County Council for the purpose
of erecting a very large imbecile asylum.
It appears that I had prepared the ground,
so all that was necessary was to erect the
buildings."
[laughter]
He never did build his flying machine. And
he turned his attentions elsewhere. But he
was so dedicated to bring scientific rigor
to this field, that he contributed immeasurably
to the field of the science of aeronautics.
He knows how he disparaged ballooning.
That's because they were a bunch of idiots
out there with balloons at the time. In his
very excellent report recently made on the
progress of aeronautics to the British Aeronautical
Society, Mr. Francis W. Berry says, "It is
singular that no one has taken advantage of
an ascertained fact to put the balloon to
more pleasurable, has more prolonged use than
has hitherto been attempted."
"After interesting how a boat may be caused
travel by the current of the stream by simply
using the pole to push clear of the banks,"
he adds, "there is every probability that
with a balloon so balanced, a push with a
long pole would sent it spinning for 50 feet
or more, and one might traverse a few hundred
yards before it neared the earth, and it required
another push."
So, they're talking about taking a balloon,
floating it so much so that it's balanced
with the lift versus the weight, just hovering
in the air. Then you can just be a gondola,
just pull yourself around. Why not, right?
[laughter]
You can drive a boat with it. "Shortly before
undertaking ascension in which he lost his
life,--
[laughter]
Donaldson, the well-known aeronaut described
to us his experience in just such balloon
sailing." Who is Mr. Donaldson? Mr. Donaldson
is Washington Harrison Donaldson. And this
guy was amazing. This guy was the guy you
think of when you think "crazy man."
[laughter]
From the 1800s, who goes around doing nonsense.
He was a circus performer who decided that
circuses were too sedate for him.
[laughter]
So, what he wanted to do was get into ballooning
and do circus acts from a balloon. So, what
he would do was go up in a balloon, cut the
basket free, and then be on a trapeze, dangling
from the balloon. And then drift across farmlands
doing trapeze acts. And people would look
up and go, "What the hell is that?"
[laughter]
Then they would follow him and when he came
down, I guess they would give him money. I'm
not sure.
[laughter]
P.T. Barnum did, eventually, like--. He got
his money from people like Barnum and giant
newspapers who were like "Put our logo on
your next balloon." And he's like, "Yes, OK.
No problem."
But he was a real pioneer in ballooning. And
he had to figure out at every step, when someone
like Barnum came and said, "I wanna build
a balloon twice as big as anything else."
Donaldson said, "No problem. I can fly it."
And he had no idea how to fly it.
[laughter]
He just had to invent it, but there were mishaps
along the way. This was his first flight.
He got the balance wrong and he had to throw
out his hat, coat, and boots to make the thing
light enough to take off. This was a later
flight.
[laughter]
That's Donaldson at the bottom. And that's
a man from the press in the middle. And up
there is, I think, a different reporter. And
what happened was a storm kicked up and Donaldson
said, "We gotta bail out. Everyone get by
the basket and hang on and then we'll all
jump at the same time.
Well, the guy--. One of the guys didn't hear
him properly. And so, Donaldson and this other
guy, Ford, they're dangling and they jump
out and the balloon shoots upward because
now it's so much lighter. And this guy is
stuck in the basket. He goes another two miles
and eventually has to jump out into a tree.
And this was par for the course.
[laughter]
So, this is from--. From this perspective,
like that's who this guy is when he says,
"Mr. Donaldson stated as his belief that if
ever the time came when people would step
into balloons as readily as they now do into
railroad cars, the airship would not sail
above the clouds, but would skim close along
the surface of the ground."
You didn't want to get too high 'cause who
knows what would happen, right? He doesn't
have a great track record with this thing.
He's like, "You can totally fly a balloon,
but just, let's keep it low."
[laughter]
"He gave many reasons for this view, notably
increased safety and economies, as balloons
could be made much smaller as they would not
require a large amount gas to keep them afloat,
and there is little difficulty in stopping
to replenish the supply when exhausted.
“He had found no trouble in balancing the
balloon four feet above the ground, and keeping
it accurately at that height for hours."
He's sitting there for hours, four feet above
the ground.
"He told us further that he frequently travelled
along country roads in this way during calm
weather, using a pole to push himself along
when there was no wind, or to guide himself
when being wafted by a breeze."
This is when you start to realize, I don't
know if he actually did this, but there's
value in newspaper's thinking you did that
because it makes you awesome in their mind.
They're like, "Donaldson? He'll do anything.
He's polling a balloon around."
[laughter]
Yet, he didn't actually have to do it to get
the article written about him. But maybe he
did.
"As an instance of how exactly a balloon can
be balanced, he stated that while thus sailing
over a road, he carelessly dropped overboard
about a quarter of a loaf of bread, whereupon
the airship sprang aloft a hundred feet or
more."
"We asked him how he avoided wagons and other
similar obstacles in his path without discharging
balance and so losing equilibrium. 'Jump over
them,' was his answer. 'A good strong push
downwards on my guiding pole has sent me flying
over many a tree, in which I had thought I
was sure to be entangled.'"
"This flee-like mode of progression was a
favorite mode he had of astonishing Arestics."
That's another phrase I wanna bring back.
Astonishing Arestics. So, here's--. Let's
go back to Maxim for just a second. "Experiments
of this character" meaning aeronautical experiments
in general, "unless conducted with great care
are exceedingly dangerous.
"No make-shift or imperfect apparatus should
be employed, but the experimenter should have
the advantage of the most perfect appliances
and apparatus that modern civilization can
afford. The necessary plan for conducting
experiments in a proper and safe manner is
unfortunately much more expensive than the
machine itself."
"If I find that my experiments require more
money than I have in my disposal, I feel sure
that some future experimenters are more fortunate
will commence where I leave off and so on."
This guy was a consummate scientist to be
looked up to by everyone in the sciences.
Meanwhile, Donaldson. The 48th ascension and
he made 130 something before he did not come
back from one, was made on May 15th, 1874.
"The villagers gathered around him like the
natives did around Columbus, and watched every
movement he made.
"After taking a sufficient number of stores,
he took his departure amid the cheers and
hurrahs of the crowd. During this trip he
engaged in the delightful sport of trailing
the drag-rope." This is the rope that hangs
from the balloon so people can grab it and
pull it back down to earth.
"Bushes would be bent over, and rail fences
jerked open with a degree of speed not common
for the farmers." So, this balloon is being
pushed by the wind. And there's an anchor
on this thing and it's just tearing through
everything in its path. "Chickens scampered
for their lives, and sheep would run in every
direction."
"As he was passing along he chanced to go
over a yard where a man and a woman were engaged
in making apple butter. Donaldson has an eye
for business, and concluded he would thicken
the apple butter for them, and at the proper
time he poured a lot of sand out of a bag
that went direct into the kettle of apple
butter."
"The woman looked up and saw, just then Donaldson
gave a few terrible blasts on his bugle and
made some remarks about 'Gabriel and the judgment.'"
[laughter]
This was the other thing he liked to do. He
carried a bugle aloft. Another flight, in
which he was flying at night, he started blowing
on the trumpet and saying, "Gabriel is here."
And all the lights would go off in all the
houses beneath as people start to pray.
"The woman took a tantrum, fell down, and
rolled over two or three times and started
for the house on 'all fours,' after the broom
and butcher knife. The man, after getting
the sand out of his face and mouth sufficiently
to see the cause of all the trouble, drew
back the ladle, and with a clenched fist,
he threatened to demolish the 'man and the
balloon.'"
"Donaldson was wafted out of sight to the
tune of that man's 'chin music' at the rate
of about 'two-forty on the pike.' The trailing
and sailing were continued for some time,
and by means of variable currents he traveled
over a big portion of Southern and Central
New York."
"After a three hours' ride he landed at Half
Way Station, between Auburn and Syracuse,
at least one hundred miles from point of starting
direct line. The gas was let out, and the
balloon shipped to Ithaca by way of Geneva.
The balloon had to remain at the depot at
Geneva all night, but as that building was
consumed by fire on the same night the balloon
was burned up."
[laughter]
This happened all the time. So, you could
never tell what was gonna happen, if you had
a delightful day of ruining apple butter,
your balloon could be consumed by a fire the
same night. Such was the life of an adventurer
in the 1800s. Nothing was taken for granted.
But everyone was consumed with the spirit
of adventure. And here is a humorous column
from Scientific American and that some of
you may relate to. "How the inventor plagues
his poor wife."
"A facetious chap connected with one of our
daily newspapers gives the following amusing
burlesque on the trials of an inventor’s
wife: 'It is all very well to talk about working
for the heathen,' said one, as the ladies
put up their sewing, 'but I’d like to have
someone tell me what I am to do with my husband.'"
"'What is the matter with him?' asked a sympathetic
old lady. 'William is a good man,' continued
the first, waving her glasses in an argumentative
way, 'but William will invent. He goes inventing
round from morning till night, and I have
no peace or comfort."
"I didn’t object when he invented a fire
escape, but I did remonstrate when he wanted
me to crawl out of the window one night last
winter to see how it worked. Then he originated
a lock for the door that wouldn’t open from
midnight until morning to keep burglars out."
"The first time he tried it he caught his
coat-tail in it, and I had to walk around
him with a pan of hot coals all night to keep
him from freezing.' 'Well, why didn’t he
take his coat off?' 'Well, I wanted him to,
but he stood around till the thing opened
itself, trying to invent some way of unfastening
it."
"That’s William’s trouble. He will invent.
A little while ago he got up a cabinet bedstead
that would shut and open without handling.
It went by clockwork. William got into it,
and up it went. Bless your heart, he stayed
in there from Saturday afternoon till Sunday
night, when it flew open and disclosed William
with the plans and specifications of a patent
washbowl that would tip over just when it
got so full."
"The result was that I lost all my rings and
a breastpin down the wastepipe. Then he got
up a crutch for a man that could also be used
as an opera-glass. Whenever the man leaned
on it up it went, and when he put it to his
eye to find William, it flew out into a crutch
and almost broke the top of his head off."
"Once he invented a rope ladder to be worn
as a guard chain and lengthened out with a
spring. He put it around his neck, but the
spring got loose and turned it into a ladder
and almost choked him to death. Then he invented
a patent boot heel to crack nuts with, but
he mashed his thumb with it and gave it up."
"Why, he has a washtub full of inventions.
One of them is a prayer book that always opens
at the right place. We tried it one morning
at church, but the wheels and springs made
such a noise that the sexton took William
by the collar and told him to leave his fire
engines at home when he came to worship."
"The other day I saw him going up the street
with a model of a grain elevator sticking
out of his hip pocket, and he is fixing up
an improved shot-tower in our bedroom."
When I read this, it made me think there's
something about human nature that doesn't
change over time.
[laughter]
And here's another wonderful example of that.
This is Nature. This is the evidence that
not everybody is as excited about progress.
If you've never heard, I'm sure you have,
the idea that the kids today, the technological
advances we have are--.
We're losing something important about our
humanity. My thesis is that we always felt
that way. Always. Even back when, a hundred
years ago, when we feel like things may have
been simpler.
[reads article]
"Now, new penalties and distresses persistently
and inexorably follow each new invention,
and that which man believes to be for his
melioration inevitably bears a satellite of
evil in its train."
"Fresh calamities and new diseases not only
come to view, but they are discovered to be
actually produced by the novel appliances
which have been regarded as benefits and wonderful
improvements. Household conveniences beget
unexpected annoyances, rapid locomotion involves
fatalities, and mechanical contrivances to
reduce labor impoverish multitudes while they
benefit the few."
"Indeed, it may be stated as a postulate,
on general principles, that the ratio of evil
is a hundred to one of good accomplished by
man’s inventions. But man’s progressive
works are not only destroying himself, but
they are hastening the destruction of the
Earth, in whose ultimate fate mankind is commonly
involved."
"It may well be questioned whether, in view
of the startling and unforeseen consequences
of scientific success which have changed the
aspect and economy of the entire globe within
the last fifty years, we have not overstepped
the moral bounds of science by perverting
the knowledge which Man came into possession
of surreptitiously when he ate of the 'forbidden
fruit.'"
"When Benjamin Franklin first called down
the lightning from the sky he was accursed
by the superstitious or reverential with 'tempting
the Almighty.' Now we handle the subtile element,
electricity, as if it were inert matter, and
we impress it into our nurseries as a toy
for the children!"
"We tap the bowels of the earth and subject
to our domestic use the vapors. We experiment
with the volcano and the geyser, the mysterious
medicine spring and the poisoned valley. We
toy with the weirdest phenomena of Nature
as if they were familiar spirits."
"We have builded a Tower of Babel at Paris,
and we have phonographed the breath of life
so that the dead may speak years after they
have departed from the earth." And not like
the glossograph. "For years we have been attempting
to make water burn" no idea what he means
there, "perverting the Divine economy to the
economy of Man, and reversing the purposes
of the Creator."
"As soon as ever the effort is crowned with
success, the destruction of the world is no
longer a question of centuries, but of years.
At present our most dangerous pet is electricity:
in the telegraph, the street lamp and the
telephone."
"We have introduced electric power into our
simplest domestic industries, and we have
woven this most subtle of agents, once active
only in the sublimes manifestations of Omnipotence,
like a web about our dwellings, and filled
our atmosphere with the filaments of death."
"It is urged that electric lighting is not
essential to the public comfort. It is not
a necessity but a luxury. By abolishing it
we reduce our danger appreciably. The telegraph
is essential to rapid intercommunication in
this age, and will be retained, but its operation
must be subjected to proper safeguards."
"The telephone is the most dangerous of all
because it enters into every dwelling. Its
interminable network of wires is a perpetual
menace to life and property. In its best performance
it is only a convenience. It was never a necessity.
In a multitude of cities its service is unsatisfactory
and is being dispensed with."
Some things do not change. "Already the conservative
public has taken the alarm, and it has become
our urgent duty, in the interest of personal
safety, think of the children, to clip the
pinions of the winged messenger and draw its
claws."
"Measures are in order to undo the mischief
as rapidly as possible and to get back to
as safe a condition as we were before."
So, there's always two sides to everything.
And I also found people who objected to the
invention of the printing press and the notion
of writing, itself.
[laughter]
I think what we do as humans is fear change,
not the technology in particular, but simply
things that are different. This is a comic
from Punchinello Magazine, which is the New
York version of the great London satirical
Punch.
And we've got a lecture there giving a talk.
Maybe the talk we just heard. The lady there,
with the ear trumpet. Fellow there in the
back kinda snoozing. And here's a guy trying
to take notes up in the front. The lecturer
says, "There is a cumulative approximativeness,
so to speak, a period when the recalcitrant
corpuscles begins to--."
And the stenographer is thinking, “Confound
the fellow! I knew he’d break my pencil
with his infernal jaw-smashers!” Jaw-smashers
I would like to bring back.
[laughter]
I'm taking notes. And the humor of this age
is really, really interesting to me as well
because it speaks to so much of the national
character, but also a sensibility of how to
tell stories that has really changed over
time.
For example, here's a little joke that was
published in Harper's. "I was perambulating
the piazza of the blank Hotel, in company
with the daughter of the landlord. She had
been recounting to me all her father's little
successes and reverses in life ever since
he had adopted the profession of a Boniface,
and among the latter, that is, the reverses,
the rather prominent and discouraging one
of having his 'hostelrie' burned down without
the mitigating circumstance of any insurance
upon it.
"I professed a proper amount of sympathy for
so great a calamity, and ventured to inquire
whether accident or the torch of the incendiary
had wrought such ruin. 'How?' inquired Rustica.
'Was it the work of an incendiary?' I repeated."
"She looked at me with a puzzled air for a
moment, and then, ''No,' said she, slowly
shaking her head, 'no; someone set fire to
it. I held in by a strong effort; but feeling
that an explosion was imminent, I rushed madly
away.' "That’s my favorite part where they
overshoot the punch line by about a sentence
and a half.
[laughter]
And this is another one. This is from a little
bit later. "A Criticism of the Theatrical
Criticism in this Morning’s Paper."
[laughter]
"The criticism by Sharpley Harpoon, in this
morning’s Star, of last night’s performance
of 'Sheets and Pillow-cases,' started off
promisingly. For two paragraphs it seemed
that originality had at last come into its
own in dramatic criticism.
“Here, finally, you felt, was a dramatic
critic whose one idea had not been to get
to bed. Rare knowledge of the theatre was
shown in every one of the first two paragraphs.
The critic had actually seen the show. The
remaining twenty-six paragraphs were something
else again.
“While there was still in fact, stronger
evidence that the critic had seen the show
he was criticizing, there began to appear,
in the third paragraph, an unmistakable sleepiness.
The suggestion of 'Sheets and Pillow-cases'
was too much for Mr. Harpoon.
“His third paragraph was a stifled 'hum-hum-hum';
his fourth paragraph was a frank yawn. And
at the start of the fifth paragraph it was
perfectly obvious that he had used scissors
and paste, for the next sixteen paragraphs
were given up entirely to a revelation of
the plot.
“Nobody who read those sixteen paragraphs
will care to see the show; they robbed the
story of any interest that it might possibly
have. But, it is safe to say, nobody read
them, so the sum total of nightly attendances
at 'Sheets and Pillow-cases' will be in no
way affected by Mr. Harpoon’s criticism.
“On the whole, the criticism was much too
appreciative, as are all criticisms today.
When shall we have dramatic critics who will
condemn ninety-five plays out of a hundred?
It makes little difference which ninety-five.
They all need it."
[laughter]
"If dramatic critics will just do that for
a while, until the public again has some confidence
in their discretion, they may then increase
the number gradually. But even the 'gladdest'
of critics should not be permitted to appreciate
more than fifteen plays out of a hundred."
"We should have a criticism censorship to
see to that. As for the last eight paragraphs
of Mr. Harpoon’s comments, it was clear
that he wrote them standing up, putting on
his hat and coat all the while. He must have
been half way out of the office before the
last paragraph was complete."
"When, oh, when, will our dramatic critics
quit going home before they write their criticisms?
It almost makes us drowsy to write about Mr.
Harpoon’s criticism of 'Sheets and Pillow-cases.'
Even we critics of critics must watch ourselves,
or we shall give occasion for the creation
of a new professional group: critics of critics
of critics."
[laughter]
"Is it possible that a person may become too
smart to criticize anything except criticism,
or criticism of criticism? Perhaps that is
why we have so few first-rate first-hand critics
today."
[laughter]
And then, like I said, all kinds of great
information for you. Here's a Philadelphia
record almanac with food and drinks for sick
people. Beef tea for the sick. You guys will
love this recipe. Take careful notes.
"One pound of lean beef, cut into small pieces."
No problem. Got it. "Put into jar without
a drop of water." OK, we can do that. "Cover
tightly." Easy. "Set in a pot of cold water."
We got all that stuff here. "Heat gradually
to a boil—fine, and continue this steadily
for three or four hours until the meat is
like white rags." That's kinda gross. "And
the juice is all drawn out. Season with salt
to taste, and when cold, skim. The patient
will often prefer this ice-cold to hot." Sounds
disgusting.
[laughter]
The beef tea is one of those nutritive drinks
you see all the time in the Victorian era.
This has got so much nutrients in them. This
is like toast water.
[laughter]
You want some toast water? Here's how you
make it and this is at home. "Carefully remove
the crust from a slice of stale bread. Toast
the slice through on both sides, but do not
burn it.
“Break the slice into three or four pieces
and put them in a pitcher with a small piece
of orange or lemon peel. Pour on a pint of
boiling water, cover up with a napkin, and
when cold, strain off the water for use. It
should be freshly made, especially in warm
weather." So, it's not toast. It's just water
that toast has been in.
[laughter]
But if that's not hardy enough for you, how
about some toast soup? "Take a thin slice
of stale wheat bread and toast until it is
brown through and through; but be careful
that you do not burn it." If you burn it,
it ruins the toast soup.
[laughter]
"While it is still hot, spread some butter
over it, but no more than will strike into
the bread without leaving any on the surface.
Now break it into fragments, put the pieces
into a pitcher, and pour on rather more than
half a pint of boiling water. A little pepper
and salt improves the taste, so they may be
added."
"This drink is usually found very acceptable
to sick or delicate persons, and at the same
time is quite nutritious." So, bachelors.
What else we got? We got some brandy. Nothing
else, just brandy."
[laughter]
"When brandy is ordered for a sick child,
it is meant that a few drops, according to
the age, should be given in water or some
sweet milk as often as the condition of the
patient requires it. Unless told to do otherwise,
keep it in reserve for the time of the day
when the sufferer appears to exhibit signs
of being weaker than usual, and then give
enough to restore it to its average condition
in health, trying not to get above that."
[laughter]
"Usually it is more frequently needed in the
latter part of the day, or quite early in
the morning, than at other times." Basically,
anytime. Milk punch. Milk punch and beef tea
were like the Adam and Eve of Victorian medicinal
concoctions. “Pour two tablespoonfuls of
good brandy into six tablespoonfuls of sweet
milk, and add two teaspoonfuls of ground loaf
sugar.
"Grate some nutmeg into it, and the punch
is ready for use." Sounds simple, right? "An
adult person can take a tablespoonful of this
every two or three hours, but for infants
or children you must remember that one-fourth
of it is brandy."
[laughter]
"Milk-punch is much ordered by physicians
for people who have low fevers and for those
who are debilitated." Milk punch was so popular
back in the Victorian era. I found as many
different recipes for milk punch as I found
citations for. This one has the rind of Seville
oranges and lemons.
It uses rum. Typically, it's some sort of
citrus zest with rum or brandy in with some
sweet milk or cream. It's really good, right?
Mr. Countryhouse takes a milk punch.
[laughter]
I told you how they loved puns, right? So,
essentially, any term that exists in the culture
is liable for a treatment like this. This
is my favorite image, maybe in the world.
[laughter]
When I first found it, I had no idea what
milk punch was.
[laughter]
I thought, "All right. It's a milk punch.
Look at that guy."
[laughter]
So I thought, "Man, I guess that's what it's
called when a cow kicks you in the gut." That's
a milk punch. All right.
[laughter]
I love this so much, I had to go learn about
milk punch. Now, it's a little less special
for me. But still, it holds a special place
in my heart. And here's an ad for Chesterfield
cigarettes. "How I Saved a Policeman's life."
And it's a little poem if I can read it.
[David Malki clears throat]
"Even the eggs were tired that morning
and the coffee didn't fool me one bit.
But when after breakfast my cigarette tasted
awful.
It was too much and a grouch started.
And walking to work, I swore off smoking
And decided to fire my office boy.
But just before I decided to kill a policeman,
A man passed me smoking a cigarette.
I must say, the smoke that drifted back did
smell good.
I followed him into a store.
He threw down two dimes and said, 'The same.'
And so did I.
So, I'm still smoking and still keep that
office boy
And let that handsome policeman live.
And--"
It's really very small. Yeah.
"That man I followed
I'm going to essentially nominate.
That man I followed for President or something.
For really, those cigarettes do satisfy."
I like that he was about to kill a policeman.
[laughter]
And this is how you sell cigarettes. I did
that in an Obama voice because I could figure
in like, it's got his cadence to it. "It was
too much. I swore off smoking, so I decided
to fire my office boy." But not kill a policeman.
You could probably not run this ad today.
[laughter]
So, milk punch is my favorite image. "A Bad
Boy's First Reader" is my favorite book ever.
Frank Bellew, a character cartoonist. This
is a book for children. So, Victorian children's
literature had one thing in common, it tells
children to sit down and shut up and not doing
anything of interest at all.
And stay out of their parent's way. That's
the unifying field theory of Victorian children's
literature. So, here is a book of virtue,
ostensibly. A little novelette book. "A, A
Lad." All right, it's gonna start with A.
That's all right. "A lad with a gun. Can the
lad shoot the gun? No, but the gun can shoot
the lad, if not careful."
[laughter]
All right. New lesson with kids. "B Boy. Has
this boy a new toy hoe? Yes, this boy has
a new toy hoe. Can the boy use his new toy
hoe? Oh yes, the boy can use his new toy hoe."
He's smashing things around there.
[laughter]
"C Cove. Here is a nice cove. Is there a boat
in the cove? Oh yes, there is a boat in the
cove, and there is a cove in the boat." All
right, I'll help you out here. Cove is old-fashioned
slang for a guy. So, this is a pun. This is
a pun. It took me a while to get it, but it's
a pun.
"D Dog. A tree, a man, and a dog. The tree
gives umbrageous protection to the man. The
man owns the dog, and the dog guards the man.
The dog is a noble animal." Look at that dog.
[laughter]
That is not a noble animal. In fact, there
is nothing noble about the tree, the man,
or the dog.
[laughter]
"E Egg. See, the boy has an egg. Can the boy
suck the egg? Oh no, the boy can not suck
the egg. It is a bad egg." Look at that bad
egg. He does not like that egg. So, don't
do that kids. "U Ewe." We're gonna skip forward
a little bit.
[laughter]
Maybe not the right message to send. "Here
are some ewe lambs. Do ewe lambs play cards?
Oh no, they do not play cards, but they gambol
on the green." Right? See? Very clever.
[laughter]
So, this is one of the books where it starts
to take a turn. "V Verily." All right, not
the best word maybe for V, but it's a weird
word. "Verily, my son, here is a fine large
fish. Do you think he is a trout? No, I think
he must be a Smelt, for I smelt him." All
right, good job guys.
[laughter]
"W Where. Where are the figs and the nuts
and the plums and the cakes? Did this boy
eat the figs and the nuts and plums and the
cakes? Oh yes, the boy did eat the figs and
the nuts and the plums and the cakes!" Look
how he regrets eating those figs and nuts
and plums and cakes. Don't do this, kids.
You'll feel horrible. "X Xcel."
[laughter]
"Here is a fine boy who wants to excel in
his class." They do know how to spell it.
[laughter]
“Does he know his lessons? No, he does not,
but he is going over them." This is starting
to be a stretch. "Y Year. See the pig and
the dog. The pig cries week! week! week. Should
the pig cry week! week? Oh no, he should not
cry week! week, for he is taken by the ear
(year)." That's a real stretch.
[laughter]
All right. So, here we go. Let's get the Z.
"Z Zebra."
[laughter]
"Is this a zebra? No,--
it is the ornithorhynchus paradoxus. He is
by the stream. Is the ornithorhynchus paradoxus
a species of duck-billed platypus? Oh yes,
the ornithorhynchus paradoxus is a species
of duck-billed platypus." I think the book
is sending the wrong message.
[laughter]
It was odd. Here's a little more of an ancillary
material. "That is right. Kick the pig out
of the house. The pig should be in the sty
or in the mud. He must not live in the house."
This is where you get a window into the society
of the time. How often is this a concern?
[laughter]
Look at that pig. The pig is not enjoying
this, this process at all. "Here is an ass.
Can an ass fly? Oh no, an ass can not fly,
but a good many have tried, in a balloon."
[laughter]
[clapping]
"This bad man has been partaking of that tortuous
stimulant known as 'crooked whiskey.' Is it
not reprehensible to partake of such potent
alcoholic beverages?" I think this is a book
for children.
[laughter]
But I'm starting to wonder if it is. "Behold
the wise statesman! He rejoiceth that he stole
the public funds, for he hath ease and oriental
luxury. Would you remain in squalid honesty
when by stealing you may become rich and joyful?"
[laughter]
Bitterness peeping through. And finally this.
"Here is Isabella perusing a volume. She loves
to peruse, while her imbecile companions waste
their time in boisterous amusements. She will
grow up to be a wise woman if she does not
die of cerebrospinal meningitis."
[laughter]
Look at that.
For a while I thought I understood the politics
of this book, but the [inaudible]. Nobody
is safe. So, Frank Bellew, the author of this
book, is a humorist. And so, the possibility
exists that he wrote this book for a satirical
purpose.
[laughter]
He may think that it was a practical joke
on us.
[laughter]
Well, back to Watkins and Donaldson. The ass
in the balloon. This is his final ascension,
139th ascension, 1875. This was an attempt
to cross the Atlantic. He had with him two
men, reporters both and there was to be a
third, but there was not--. They had to take
too many provisions and there wasn't the ability
to carry the fourth man in the balloon.
So, they had to flip a coin. One man got to
go and the other man stayed behind. 1875.
"Near five P. M. the 'P. T. Barnum'"--which
was the name of the balloon that Barnum had
paid for--" left the Hippodrome, carrying
Washington Harrison Donaldson, one of the
world's greatest and best aeronauts, and Newton
S. Grimwood, reporter for the Chicago Evening
Journal."
"The balloon, with its 83 thousand cubic feet
of gas, and 800 pounds of sand, and two passengers,"
so it was just Washington and Grimwood, there
was a third man that had to stay behind. "Rose
gracefully to an altitude of about five thousand
feet, and floated steadily to the northeast,
out over Lake Michigan, and in a direction
that would, if followed, take them near Grand
Haven, Michigan, 120 miles distant."
"Thousands of upturned eyes watched the graceful
balloon as it moved steadily before the breeze
at a rate of about fifteen miles an hour.
At 6:30, one hour and a half from the time
of starting, many eyes were yet fastened upon
the balloon, anxious, perhaps, about the descent,
or wishing that a counter-current would send
them back."
"Loved ones looked with eager eyes until tears
blurred the balloon from their sight, and
as the balloon faded from view darkness enveloped
the city, and speculation was already rife,
and anxiety manifested itself in many minds."
"At seven P. M. the 'Little Guide,' standing
out some thirty miles from the Illinois shore,
off Grosse Point, and about twelve miles north
of Chicago, " this is a boat, "sighted the
balloon, and observing it occasionally dipping
the basket in the lake, only a mile and a
half distant."
Trying that poling thing probably. "The ' Little
Guide' headed for the balloon, but before
it could overtake the balloon there seemed
to be a sudden lightening of the car, and
the air ship shot upward to a great height
and soon disappeared from the view of the
crew of the schooner."
So we know why there is occasionally a sudden
lightening of the balloon and his body was
found about a month later and Grimwood, the
passenger. "This was the last that was ever
seen of the balloon. That night a terrific
storm swept down upon the lake, a hurricane
whose volume and fury none can know added
terror to the Cimmerian darkness."
"Powerful indeed must be the pen that could
describe a midnight hurricane from their standpoint,
the intensity of night made brilliant by the
flashes of lightning, the quietude disturbed
by the pealing thunder that would seem to
shake the world asunder. The awful position,
that they could scarcely realize no doubt,
palsied them with fear.
"Yea, though they were brave, yet when death
comes so plain, what heart would not tremble?
Their suffering, their agony, their terror,
their heart-rending cries, and their thoughts
of friends and home, none can know. Donaldson,
brave, heroic and skilled, no doubt strained
every nerve to protect his passenger, and,
like the bold, the noble and true captain,
sank with Grimwood to a watery grave."
Donaldson's body was never found. The New
York Times reported he was found in a barn
like a month later, but that's like the Elvis-sighting
kind of deal. And that was never verified.
But this is what Donaldson said on an earlier
occasion. This is a guy who, remember, made
a point.
He invented the art of trapeze ballooning.
"I have noted on different occasions a class
of people who were only half alive and who
find fault with my exercise, which to them
looks frightful. Their nervous system is not
properly balanced."
"They have too much nerves for their system,
which is caused by want of a little moderate
exercise up there where the air is pure, instead
of which they spend hours in a place which
they call their office."
"They sit themselves in a dark corner, hidden
from the sun's rays, and in one position remain
for hours, inhaling the poisonous air with
the room full of carbonic acid gas," carbon
dioxide , "which is as poisonous to man as
arsenic is to rats; and in addition to this,
will fill their lungs with tobacco smoke,
and to steady their nerves require a stimulation
of perhaps eight or ten brandies a day."
Well, maybe they just weren't feeling well.
"If I were as helpless as this class of people,
then my life would be swinging by a thread,
and I would wind up with a broken neck." He
preferred the life in the balloon to any safe
life on the ground. 1879, Frank Leslie's Popular
Monthly.
"Modern civilization may well be described
by the words so generally applied to fire:
'A good servant, but a bad master.' At no
previous period have the appliances for easy
and comfortable living been so numerous or
so generally distributed among all classes,
and the men of today have much cause for congratulation
compared even with those of a generation since."
“Whether for purposes of business or pleasure,
the number of man's servants has of late greatly
increased. The telegraph, the telephone, the
locomotive and the steamship, the modern printing
press, and thousands of minor devices which
add immensely to the sum total of his pleasures,
are all willing servants if properly used."
"But once in control, they become the hardest
taskmasters. The telegraph and telephone offer
a ready and useful service at all times, but
again, they often become the most rigid fetters,
binding a man's whole life to the office and
exchange."
"Steam has increased to an enormous extent
the ease and pleasure of traveling, but it
is now too often used as a means for a rapid
rush from place to place, with none of the
pleasures which accompany more deliberate
travel; and the many other adjuncts are too
generally misapplied as a means for accumulating
a little more money or building up a short-lived
fame at the expense of health and true enjoyment."
"Men have come to live fast, rather than well."
1879. A sentiment that is fairly common today,
too. Typical issue of Scientific American
looks like this. You have all sorts of things.
There's the official list of patents, everything
that was issued in that week. A little blurb
about American inventions and Europe.
You'll get a common sense of what's going
on elsewhere in the world. Here's an article
about steam boiler encrustations. A very practical
article, so you can make sure your boiler
is functioning at top performance. Here's
an article about spontaneous combustion of
the human body.
[laughter]
But to its credit, it is debunking the notion.
And right in the middle is this. "The Maddening
Mechanism of Thought," in-between the steam
boiler encrustations and list of patents.
This essay by Oliver Wendell Holmes.
"Our brains are seventy-year clocks. The Angel
of Life winds them up once for all, then closes
the case, and gives the key into the hand
of the Angel of the Resurrection. Tictac!
tic-tac! go the wheels of thought; our will
cannot stop them ; they cannot stop themselves
; sleep cannot still them; madness only makes
them go faster; death alone can break into
the case, and seizing the ever-swinging pendulum,
which we call the heart, silence at last the
clicking of the terrible escapement we have
carried so long beneath our wrinkled foreheads.
"If we could only get at them, as we lie on
our pillows and count the dead beats of thought
after thought and image after image jarring
through the over-tired organ. Will nobody
block those wheels, uncouple that pinion,
cut the string that holds these weights, blow
up the infernal machine with gunpowder?"
"What a passion comes over us sometimes for
silence and rest, that this dreadful mechanism,
unwinding the endless tapestry of time, embroidered
with spectral figures of life and death, could
have but one brief holiday."
"Who can wonder that men swing themselves
off from beams in hempen lassos ? That they
jump off from parapets into the swift and
gurgling waters beneath ? That they take counsel
of the grim fiend who has but to utter his
one peremptory monosyllable, and the restless
machine is shivered as a case that is dashed
upon a marble floor?"
"Under that building which we pass every day
there are strong dungeons, where neither hook,
nor bar, nor bed cord, nor drinking vessel
from which any sharp fragment may be shattered,
shall by any chance be seen. There is nothing
for it, when the brain is on fire with the
whirling of its wheels, but to spring against
the stone wall and silence them with one crash."
"Ah, they remembered that, the kind city fathers,
and the walls are nicely padded, so that one
can take such exercise as he likes without
damaging himself. If anybody would really
contrive some kind of a lever that one could
thrust in among the works of this horrid automaton
and check them, or alter their rate of going,
what would the world give for the discovery?"
"Men are very apt to try and get at the machine
by some indirect means or other. They clap
on the brakes by means of opium, or they change
the maddening monotony of the rhythm by means
of fermented liquors."
"It is because the brain is locked up and
we cannot touch its movements directly, that
we thrust these coarse tools in through any
crevice by which they may reach the interior,
alter its rate of going for a while, and at
last spoil the machine."
When I talk to people who are interested in
the Victorian era and the aesthetic of it,
or their steam pumps or whatever it is, there's
a sense of like the good old days when things
were awesome. And I think the much scarier
notion is the fact that we have not changed.
And the reason that's scary is because it
implies that the things that we suffer from
now are constant. They're part of human nature
and we'll always suffer from them. And it's
very difficult to learn how to deal with that
because we think, "Oh, if only there's this
new technological advancement, this awesome
app is gonna get me organized."
Or, "this new system or this book I'm gonna
read or whatever it is." But they felt the
same way a hundred years ago as we feel today.
And so, the implication is that we're gonna
feel the same way a hundred years from now,
right? There's no way to fix it. There's no
way to make it better.
And that's a tremendously distressing thought.
So, I was thinking about this and I'm thinking,
"If this is true, what do we do? What do we
do?" And the best solution I can think of--.
I have to share it with you here. Just laugh
about it.
[laughter]
Thank you very much.
[applause]
>>Male Presenter: So, do we have--? Is the
room free?
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: What day is it?
It's Monday. No one's here already. So we
probably have it for a little while.
>>Male Presenter: So, can you hang on for
a few minutes for questions?
>>David Malki: Yeah.
>>Male Presenter: If anyone has any questions.
And it is 12 o'clock if anyone needs to be
going on to their next place. So, we'll give
you five or ten minutes for questions.
>>David Malki: Sure.Yeah.
>>Male Presenter: If anyone else wants to
come up afterwards. You have anything to say?
>>David Malki: And if not, it's OK. Don't
feel obligated.
[laughter]
If nothing else, I'm happy to sign books,
too. Thank you all. Yes.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: So, how do you
find all of these cool things? I mean, earlier
you said some people send, like send you right
these books.
>>David Malki: Yeah. Well, with the way it
started was I think I had one book of clipart
that was commercially done with clipart. And
then I realized that I was making comics using
these little engravings. And I'm like, "Well,
I could use this clipart, but everyone else
has access to the same book of cliparts."
And so, you see the same images cropping up
a lot. So I thought, "Where did the clipart
come from?" And so, luckily the books have
introductions and they say this is from such
and such magazine. So, I went to the library
in LA and they have a bunch of archives on
microfilm.
And I was able to look up those particular
magazines and newspapers that they had cited
and I thought--. Pretty soon, I had a list
of really cool images on this microfilm. I'd
write down like, such and such year and such
and such title. And then I started looking
for those exact books on eBay.
And I'd get ones that were damaged and didn't
have any collector's value because the cover
was missing or it got stained or something
or a kid had drawn over half of it. So, get
a sense of the era and the types of titles
that might have things that I'd like. And
the collection grew over time.
And then it got to the point where people
would start sending me the things after I'd
been doing it for a while. And I would look
online for, "Oh, here's Harper's 1879." But
this article is a two-parter. So, what about
Harper's 1880? What about that one? So, that's
where Google Books eventually was super helpful.
And a lot of these articles that--. I mean,
you saw some of them were scans from physical
paper, but a lot of them were from Google
Books as well because I can do research where
I can type in a certain author, like looking
up Hiram Maxim. I can see different articles
published about him.
And so that's where, at this point, Google
Books has been my whole second library that
I use for compiling extensive information
like this. Although, I can't use it to make
the comics because it's all low-res. So, until
next week.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #6: How much time do
you spend just paging through actual old books
or magazines?
>>David Malki: Umm. A lot. It's tough because
I get really captivated by it. Like, I get
started--. It's hard. You get just into the
reading and it's hard to stop. And in fact,
some of the books I got more recently, have
been other languages which makes it way easier
because I don't get sucked into it.
But when I'm making the comics, occasionally
I will have an idea for a certain figure or
character or pose, and then I have to find
something that matches that. And so that's
a matter of looking through everything with
an eye for, "I need a doctor. I need something
that looks really like a doctor. Nope, not
here."
All right. And if I was just drawing the thing,
I could just draw it.
[laughter]
But it's--. So sometimes it's, I have a lot
of fun with that. And other times it's dangerous.
It's dangerous when it gets like that. Yeah.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #7: The book, what
was it, the book for bad boys. Do you have
an impression of how that was received at
the time? Have you seen reviews of it or anything?
Is that like this?
[laughter]
>>David Malki: I wish I knew more about it.
I've seen other people excited nowadays because
they've discovered it. But I don't think it
was tremendously widely published. Like, there
are very few copies of it in print still.
Like, left in libraries I've discovered.
Although what I'm gonna do, I'm gonna be in
DC in a couple months. I'm gonna go to the
Library of Congress and if they have one,
I'm gonna scan it. And I'm gonna reprint it
because it's freaking awesome.
[laughter]
But Frank Bellew, who again, he was a humorist.
He was a characterist. He was an editorial
cartoonist. So, I get the sense that it was
written satirically. But there are other pages,
like I skipped over a bunch of them, but there
are others that are written much more straight
like a children's book.
And so, either his humor was not that good
and it was not that clever, so it seems like
you know, "I don't get the joke," or he was
towing that line between, "Yeah, this is plausibly
a children's book, but I'm gonna slip in this
super weird stuff."
[laughter]
Yeah.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #8: You said there
were historical objections to the writing.
>>David Malki: Yeah. Well, Socrates, whom
we only know because Plato wrote down his
arguments, objected to writing as a discipline.
He thought that when you wrote something down,
you weakened your mind because the only way
you can have a legitimate thought is by arguing
it out with somebody.
And when you have something written down,
it's only a one-sided argument. So, if you
read something, you're not being taught it.
You're simply being told it. You don't have
to puzzle it out with a conversation, like
with Socrates himself.
And when you write something, you are necessarily
presenting something in a lesser form than
you might be able to do by explaining it to
somebody and getting their feedback and tailoring
what you can teach them in a very particular
way. And I don't know that he ever quite sees
the import that like--.
There is nothing that persists from generation
to generation unless you write something down.
And that's where the irony comes in. We wouldn't
even know he objected to writing if Plato
hadn't written it down.
And in the same way, there was a monk who
wrote a screed called "In Defense of Scribes"
about how the printing press was going to
degrade people's understanding of scripture
because in order to really understand scripture,
you really have to spend hours transcribing
it.
And you really get into it. And if you just
are reading a printed version of it, it just
glosses past you. And of course, nobody would've
known his argument if it hadn't been printed.
[laughter]
And circulated. Yeah.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #9: Do you run into
lots of interesting people when you're paging
through 1800s magazines and microfilm?
>>David Malki: Well, like physical people
in the library?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #9: Yeah.
>>David Malki: Um. The people that are most
often in the basement of the library are homeless
people. So, I overhear interesting conversations.
Or people say, "You cannot sleep in here.
Get out." And unfortunately, there's not this
secret society, at least that I've experienced,
of researchers who are conducting interesting
experiments in the archives.
I kinda wish like, it would be great like
young adult novel is like, the kids who are
trying to solve the mystery of the old clock
by looking at newspapers and stuff. But I
have not found those kids yet.
[laughter]
Anything else? Awesome. Great, guys. Thanks
for laughing at my humor.
[applause]